It is worthwhile looking at what we call the
Brownian motion.
I hope you've heard of this.
Robert Brown was a botanist here in London,
who lived about 140 years ago.
And he found that if he put small grains of
pollen and looked at them with his microscope,
put them in suspension in water, and looked
at them with his microscope,
he often saw them, he often looked carefully,
dancing forever.
Whether they were... even if they were dead,
they appeared to dance,
he thought at first it was because they were
living.
And then people learned that you can do it
with powdered sand, anything whatever.
It dances incessantly. If it is small enough
and we look at it under the microscope.
I think if you'll watch Bill put the microscope
on a sample,
which contains a fine suspension of red powdered
pigment,
in the suspension of water.
And the microscope can magnify it up, and
when it has adjusted,
the magnification of about 60-100 times, you
will see...
lights down I think please.
You will see on the screen the in focus moving
particles.
Notice how they dance forever.
It's worth watching. It's a beautiful sight.
And this has nothing whatever to do with their
life or their nature.
Any particles, sufficiently small, placed
in a fluid or in a gas
where they're free to move, will show this
motion,
if only the system is at the temperature of
the room.
You can't get rid of this motion, no matter
what you do,
we'll talk about that in the last lecture
quite a lot.
Notice how it goes in a random way.
Now to give some feeling what's going on,
we have a model here.
In the model, which you will see projected
on the screen,
we have a set of mock molecules.
No, I think we want lights down, please.
Mock molecules which are simply small steel
ball bearings.
64th of an inch across, like the Feinman motor.
Magnified up here.
And caused to move by a magnetic field which
is whirling around,
causing their moving off in a somewhat random
way.
Notice they're not precisely random, they
tend to stick together just as you'd expect.
And they fly in all directions at that impurity,
like a big piece of pink pigment,
which we will show you presently. Just a piece
of paper.
And it is sometimes hit on one side, sometimes
on the other.
And since the number of molecules it hitted
is random, why of course,
sometimes there's an unusual number on the
left, and not so many on the right,
in which case it moves to the right. And so
it goes.
It does that random dance.
And that's exactly what is happening in the
real Brownian motion
which we can look at again.
In the real Brownian motion, you cannot see
the molecules,
all you can see are the large impurities,
moving about as the molecules irregularly
press them in one direction or another,
because the molecules of course are in constant
motion
and the Brownian motion is the reflection
of molecular motion
by things that are large enough to be seen
in the microscope.
Even a brick would show Brownian motion but
the motion is so small
that we can't detect it. Only in small particles
does the scaling allow its detection.